hello and welcome oh that's very loud
whoop hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and it's
time for a game of who shung shuang
shuang hardest for gone gone gone if
this is your favorite show
please like subscribe and swing on into
the comments to give us your thoughts on
the outcome of this hard-hitting
swinging mess
that is hunter hunter and we'll come
back to this next time
on the one side we have newcomer hair
loser kilwa bashabiski
don't she look cute but don't let that
cutesy red-eyed demon look
fool ya behind that adorable bakery
sweet look is the 57 year old heart of a
gem hoarder
on the other side we have our best
friend your favorite
my favorite our favorite hiskey give him
a swing his key let him know you mean it
come on hiskey you can do better than
that
schwing much better now since hisoka's
not currently on greed island we're
going to have to see whether biski can
get ahead in these first questions
first question for the comments who has
a weirder view of these kids
biscuit with the gemstone desire or
hisoka with just his general
well crotchety while you consider let's
review episodes 62 and 63.
and would you look at that the creepy
kid is actually a creepy grown-up
shortbread who looks like a kid because
she's experienced exactly what the boys
get to look forward to
learning then too early stunts your
growth big time no matter how much
oatmeal you chomp down
why this smart cookie's decided to cling
onto our kids here no one knows but she
has and i for one am glad
we finally get someone around here who
understands how to think logically
yes she's an adult and everyone up to
now has been an actual child but
it's nice to see the reverse of the la
audio effect where we have an
individual older than advertised on the
packaging i am
glad she exists and am glad she's
finally stepped out of the shadows to
blaze in the glorious burning rage fires
of her dislike of quiloia kilwa's
treatment of her really takes the pisket
and it's going to be piscot and it's
going to be fun seeing how they
antagonize each other as we go along
especially since god seems to have a
sweet tooth and be happy enough to do
exactly what she says
while kilwa remains suspicious of her
intentions and is unlikely to crumble
like the clever boy he is
well i say clever but the two of them
have been struggling with the mechanics
of this game
as the gamer and given how excited both
of them were
it seems odd that they didn't think of
using their abilities in game mechanic
terms
if something doesn't work you try
increasingly absurd ways until one of
them does work or at least i do
that's how i play anyway it was
interesting to see the seven psychopaths
interacting with the world by seven i
mean our two children and our five
phantom troopers who have joined it
so far all the ways they're dealing with
the world are ways that would basically
be how most
people play video games the most
fascinating part of this is that how
they behave in the real world becomes
the state of play in this one it takes
us to that
fun research around whether video games
are violent or whether violent people
play video games
in this world we can only really come to
the conclusion that violent people play
this particular video game because every
single one of those hunters is willing
to kill
or maim to get what they want more the
phantom troop and gone and kilwa are
having a ball because this is exactly
what they
want to have the freedom to do whatever
they want whenever they want to to the
phantom troop members
this actually changes nothing at all
nothing at all
nothing at all nothing at all nothing at
all
they learned new information about the
world but it doesn't change how they
interact with it
gone and killer strongly believe they're
in a game so they're actively treating
it like one
the problem with what tall big eyed and
technical said about greed island is
that it's based or located in a real
place
that means a lot of things one of which
is that maybe gone's dad is
or was nearby maybe maybe probably not
but at least he'd have an eye on his son
at that point the other factoid to come
out of that though
is the idea that each of the non-player
characters in this game are actually
real people
watch the scene where gon and kilwa are
trying to figure out what they'll get as
a result of helping and watch them
asking if the illness is contagious
watch that scene as if the people
they're trying to help
are actually real people hearing
everything they say and listening with a
small child
dying in a bed it changes everything
about that scene
in this case i'm not blaming gon and
keela of course they couldn't have known
these thoughts but
it really opens your eyes to the way
people treat characters in games versus
how they treat them in real life
that said we can even look at that gon
and kilwa wouldn't have even engaged
with them at all if kilwa hadn't thought
of game mechanics and questioned whether
they would get things they needed
information or items the mechanics of
the game are specifically
in this case encouraging them to do
humanitarian work while specifically
engaging their lack of humanity to do it
and that's such a cool way of looking at
the scene it's such an exciting and new
concept
jumping from them to the other group for
a moment one of the other hunter groups
i guess what do we call them
antagonists our leads are sort of
anti-hero protagonists so we'll go with
antagonists until someone gives me a
better name
anyway we have the phantom troupe who
will want i think to take everything out
of the game
they're completionists who want to
finish the game and gon
and killa are also completionists but in
the
actually completing the game way with
this
manga and show ever supposed to have a
physical component because we're getting
so much
card game mechanic that i wonder whether
takashi planned on
creating an accompanying video and card
game system we have skylanders these
days so i can imagine he dreamed of it
i'll dream of it too it sounds kind of
fun
anyway that group of people are giving
me the distinct feeling they've been
looped into a cult and that's kind of
creepy if i say so myself
you will bring us spell cards so that we
can protect
the ultimate spell card yes yes we will
bring you the protector card for the
ultimate spell card
know what i mean weird vibes coming off
that group anyway
let's move on to episode 63 and see what
our mini femme hisoka has in store for
these two
episode 63 creepy kid doesn't want to
connect with her pastry based name
because that's apparently too formal
bisky it is
this episode sort of left me confused
there was some intense posturing and
level setting this episode so
let me first say that i love the
interactions between quiloia
and biscuit sorry everyone i am in fact
more formal that out of the way
i found it fairly strange that biscuit
is wings trainer cute little wing
isn't the world a fun place we all know
each other great
anyway biscuits way of training the boys
is by catching a serial killer and
telling them that they have to kill each
other it's a very strange
you're in a pit good luck situation but
i guess it's also the first time
gonz had someone cut and dry enough to
tell him exactly what's happening and
what the boundaries are
he's been setting his own boundaries the
whole time he's been traveling and while
it's been interesting the thing i
remember most from wing
is wing putting the requirement on him
not to use his nan
beyond that i don't think anyone has put
boundaries on this kid beyond mito
there's something about his willingness
to follow that i find incredibly
endearing but also
somewhat frightening while he can make
decisions for himself and has his own
moral code his first instinct is to
follow
however kilwa's first instinct is to
lead both are happy to shift that stance
depending on the situation but they have
their inclinations the fun thing about
this
is that while kilwa likes to lead and
someone else comes in to
break him or slow him enough to see why
it makes sense that he'd listen
basically doesn't bother to tell him why
she explains it to gone and when gone
makes a decision she knows they will
both stay
that sounds counterintuitive to what i
just said but think of gon and kilwa as
twins
one twin is the quote-unquote dominant
one and the other one is the
quote-unquote submissive one
kilwa is a submissive one who acts
dominant while gone
is the dominant energy who acts
submissive all that makes sense with
their nen really kiwa can alter the
flavor of an event while gon can
heighten the energy of it overall gone
makes the event happen
keewa's support for now anyway we'll see
what happens later either way
biski didn't bother with kilauea's
responses she focused on guns and
dismissed kilauea several times punching
him satisfyingly
into the air halfway through the episode
we found out about binol's terrifyingly
miserable history
now here's where i question why why did
we need to know about this
why did we need to feel bad for this
serial killer realistically we didn't
need that information any more than we
needed or
need information about schmick and shady
so why give it to us
was takashi trying to inject a little
humanity into a situation where
everyone was acting like pretty intense
psychopaths because it changed the
entire
flavor of the episode for me it changed
the situation from two kids fighting an
adult because their weird teacher told
them to
to two kids forcing a traumatized third
party to fight
it's really strange and discomforting
because i didn't want to feel bad for
binault i wanted to be able to watch
kilauea and gone learn how to fight
rather than mining the poor guy for
strength and power essentially
camping his abilities by waiting for him
to recover in truth
it wasn't a very enjoyable episode for
that reason i felt that my empathy was
being manipulated and while that was
sort of okay for what's-his-name who
loved neon's maid i did not enjoy my
empathy being harnessed purely to make a
serial killer look good
after trying to kill small children or
what he thought was small children
either way it's weird it's a weird
experience to have and i'm still not
sure how i feel about it it's great i'm
sure that takashi could do that that he
had the ability to take our emotions and
pull them around like that
but i felt cheated as though he'd stolen
what could have been a victorious
experience away from me i suppose it
comes back to the content of the last
episode and game mechanics
except applied to us the audience where
gon and kilwa responded to mechanics in
the previous episode as though they
weren't real people because as far as
they know they're not
we or i i suppose responded to this
situation with discomfort because
of the cognitive dissonance of
originally wanting this guy to die
because he's just a narrative device
before having that turned on its head
and pointed out that he's a victim
too it's not fair oh and biski's 57
no but she said she took the hunter exam
40 years ago couldn't have been exactly
40 years ago because that is not
my friend that is not the body of a 17
year old i'm just saying
i don't care how much hair is eaten that
ain't it i can do basic math
and biski i was actually right huzzah
she's the creepy femme version of hisoka
that's ah
i don't know how okay i am with her it's
great that she understands what she
wants and she can train them but the
idea that she sees their potential as
precious stones to be honed
is she going to swing like hisoka how
does her schwing present
is her hair going to suddenly spraying
back into existence
as they hone into diamonds and sapphires
and she daydreams about them will they
become
everything she ever wanted she knows who
ging jing she knows who jing is and he's
famous
is he younger or older than she is one
of the top five men users huh with god's
bottomless potential does that mean he
could overtake
jing to be the top five nin user all by
himself
all the top five men users it's really
hard to say top five and
five top five men top five nine users ha
ha
honestly what few brain cells gone had
before were very visible on his head
while he fell asleep over and over
which was actually kinda hilarious so i
don't know if he is smart enough anymore
but hey
who needs to be intelligent to use nen
they learned a new ability and that's
the important part right
at least that's what gon thinks i have
more thoughts on the matter but now is
not the time for them because that's it
from me
if you think there should be a crossover
swing between biski and hiskey hit the
like button
then hit the subscribe button then check
out this video maybe this one
and relax while watching this one and
i'll see you next time